Jairus, 300 billion people are counting on you, so don't choke!
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean.
I'm Joe. And I'm Sam.
I don't know, I feel like there's got to be more than 300 billion people in a fully functioning galaxy that has, you know, that has, like, figured out time, not time travel, but space travel at the least.
Yeah, but you only ever see our solar system, in which case you assume it's only the Earthlings, right?
300 billion Earthlings, okay.
Yeah, that's a lot of Earthlings, though.
There could be, like, a couple of things going on, like, Mars at this point, but beyond that, I don't know if we could get any more.
Yeah. It's weird.
It's a weird number.
Did it say people, or did it say, like, life forms?
People. Oh, okay.
And it is AD 2500, so, um, is that how you would say that year, if we were living in that year?
It just feels wrong. I think it'd be 2500.
2500, right. Because we were living in the year 2000, so I thought, like, maybe you would say 2500, but I like the year 2500 better.
I feel like if you were, like, in the year 1900, you'd say 1900, right?
That's what we used to say.
That's also true. That's what we used to say.
We never said we were in the year 1900.
Of our lord. We should have.
Only of our lord. This is legendary NES shmup developer Konami.
Don't be fooled by that ultra game stuff.
This was developed by Konami.
And, uh, the reason why I say legendary NES shmup developers specifically because a lot of their games have a great chance of being on our essential games list.
Uh, Lifeforce, Gradius, uh, even Stinger was on there for a minute.
So, uh, sky's the limit, or maybe solar system's the limit in this game, uh, for what they're capable of.
Yeah. And I did say Gyrus at the start of this episode.
We kind of joked at the end of last episode, how do you say this?
I went on the ArcadeMuseum.com to find out how to pronounce Gyrus.
And, basically, people were saying, well, it's not Greek.
So you wouldn't say it like Yyrus.
That's what I was saying.
That's enough proof for me. That's all that they could, is that all that they could, uh, rule out?
Just that it's not Greek?
I think eventually the conclusion was Gyrus, but I guess there's no reason why it can't be Gyrus.
Yeah. I mean, if it means anything, whether or not there was actually, like, a real way to say it, I'd still say Gyrus.
That's all I need to know.
So, uh, two people can't be wrong.
Uh, you know, that's the fail-safe system around here.
Yeah. Anyway, it's, as I mentioned, AD 2500, and mankind has penetrated the galaxy's fringes, establishing colonies of peace from Mercury all the way to Pluto.
Suddenly, the tranquility of the Milky Way erupts into a frothing fury as armadas of alien death ship swarms.
Those are their words.
I'm not coming up with anything playful here.
These alien death ship swarms invade our solar system like killer bees preying on an innocent bystander.
You'll notice that none of these alien ships in the game look like killer bees.
So now the, like, the manual's really getting into the nitty gritty of it.
See, I don't even see that in my manual.
I think I'm reading off the arcade manual.
I think that's right. Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Uh, they mention that no one is spared by these killer bee death ship swarms.
Even beloved Mother Earth is stung.
These vicious cosmic visigoths, uh, are war-starved gyrisons, uh, and, and they're led by the immortal Genghis Khan, whom they recruited from Mongolia centuries ago.
Wow. That's incredible.
So that is, okay, because in, in, in the other manual, it just says Genghis Khan, and I thought maybe, like, oh, there's a guy who took that name, uh, you know, out of inspiration in the future or something.
They mention it just briefly that a picture of Genghis Khan appears, and that's all.
Not, not just a picture, though.
A neo-revolutionary portrait.
Yeah. Of Genghis Khan. Yeah.
Genghis Khan. And why it's neo-revolutionary, I'm not sure.
But it's great.
It also just, like, it, like, delivers that in the manual as, like, part of the instructions.
Yeah. It's like, when the opening screen appears, displaying a neo-revolutionary portrait of the savage Genghis Khan, press start.
Yeah, I love it.
That's literally what it says. It's how to save the universe, and then no backstory, and it's just, when you see the picture of Genghis Khan, press start.
I also like that they chose Genghis Khan as, like, the big reveal that, like, oh no, he didn't ever die or lose.
Actually, he was recruited by, he was so good that he was recruited by these aliens centuries ago just to wait to strike once the, like, because Earth wasn't enough for him, he needed the entire solar system to conquer.
Incredible. Also, shout out to the use of the word zaptifying, uh, describing how many stages there are.
I don't know if that's a word, or even if it was a word, if it has any meaning, but it's great.
I believe there's 39 zaptifying stages, right?
Absolutely. That's, that's correct.
So, uh, with our galactic fleet flattened, you're the lone space cowboy, again, they're words, but I love that, uh, you're the lone space cowboy who escaped the gyrus shroud of doom.
I'm in. I'm hooked.
Yeah. Sometimes we're like, you know, there's not enough investment in the story or the plots of these games to, like, understand what's going on.
I feel like this was the right level of absurdness meets, like, hell yeah attitude for me that I was like, I want to beat the game.
Like, I want to take down Genghis Khan and reclaim the solar system.
Yeah, I mean, now that you've given me, like, an extra piece of deep lore that we didn't get with the NES manual, I'm definitely down for it.
Like, just what's in the NES manual, it feels like a drunken rambling.
But when you give that context that's not in the actual manual, it definitely works better.
Yeah, the manual has a little bit of attitude in the beginning.
Like, when it's saying what the planets are, it says, uh, for those of you who flunked astronomy, those planets are Mercury, Venus, Earth, Mars, Jupiter, Saturn, Uranus, Neptune, and Pluto.
Right? Which is good.
Those are the planets.
But you don't start on Earth or Pluto, you start on Neptune, or you start by approaching Neptune.
You gotta figure that maybe you were based in Neptune, and then it was like, oh, right, right, Pluto is a planet now again in 2500, like, right, right, I gotta go back and save that too.
And then you go the other way.
Well, here's the thing, maybe what they're saying is that, uh, because the elliptical orbit of Pluto, uh, actually intersects the orbit of Neptune in 2500 AD, Pluto will be within Neptune's orbit.
Can you explain everything just in that voice going forward?
Absolutely. All right, but before we get too deep into where you go in this game and what you do, I feel like we do need to explain that this isn't, uh, the shmups like Life Force and, uh, and Gradius and stuff.
This is a little different, kind of like, uh, Tempest, but with some visual flair to it other than vectors.
Joe, do you want to give a good stab at explaining what you do in this game?
Yeah, because at my first thought, I was like, oh, this is different.
And then, like, you know, a couple seconds in, I was like, wait a minute, this is a shmup.
Like, it tricked me at first, because it's, it looks like you're going forward, you know?
It looks like it's, it looks like it's like, um, I don't know, like a more modern, like, rails shooter that's, like, in 3D space.
But what it really is, is kind of a shmup that's been, that's been rolled up into a cylinder.
So instead of going side to side on the screen, you kind of roll around the outside of the screen as, as the stars come at you and all your enemies come at you.
And it is actually kind of cool, it's a nice little change of pace.
Um, but that gives you all kinds of different things to think about.
Like, the fact that you can't shoot across the screen, because you're shooting into the center of the screen, which is, like, further in Z space.
So, I thought that that was actually a nice little, uh, a nice little refreshing touch on, on shmups.
Yeah, I, I very much appreciated that they, they did something unique with the presentation.
Um, and I guess all that you need to keep me from getting bored is to, uh, make it a circle.
So, I also thought that it, it was a refreshing shmup.
Exactly. Yeah, I, I think it really changes the way you think about your movement.
And, like, zigzagging is a lot different, and it has different implications in this than it does in a typical shmup.
And the fact that you also can't move forward and backward, I think is interesting, too.
Yeah, so you're really, you're going around in a circle here, and I think we should talk about that decision a little more of being able to only control your ship in a circle.
Because they do give you two different control choices, control A or control B.
The difference being control A, you actually use all four, uh, D-pad buttons.
So this way, as you make your way around the circle, you have to switch between using the left D-pad, the up button, the, the right.
Uh, and then control B is only using left and right, and at times that can get tricky, too, because you might be at, like, um, you know, three, you might be at three o'clock.
And now all of a sudden, left suddenly might feel different than going right if you were locked in that space for a second.
You do have to kind of keep track of where you are.
Did you guys have a preference, control A, control B?
I'm actually surprised that they made control A, which is the more context-based, uh, control scheme, uh, that they made that, like, the first choice.
Um, I guess, like, now, whenever, I don't, I can't even think of a game in which this is sort of, like, you're always going around in a circle, but, um, I would assume that it would be this control B, where you just move left and right, and depending on where you are on the screen,
that's going to move you, uh, clockwise or counterclockwise.
I, I prefer control B, uh, because it's sort of got, like, it just has that one rule, clockwise or counterclockwise.
Um, though I guess control A may make more sense to some people that, like, it's more of, like, an absolute, uh, direction.
Um, but yeah, definitely control B for me.
Yeah, I, I tried, um, control B first.
And, and I liked it, but I, you know, it did get confusing when, uh, a little bit, until you get used to it, when, um, you know, right, I don't remember which one's which, but let's say right takes you clockwise and left takes you counterclockwise.
Suddenly, when you're at the top of the screen, that feels reversed.
It's not, but it feels, when you hit right, suddenly it feels like you're going left.
Well, you are going left, but you're going to the ship's right.
You know what I mean? Yeah.
So that would get confusing once in a while.
So I thought, okay, let me, let me start over and I'll try it with control scheme A.
Um, because then I can just press the direction that I want to end up in.
If I want to end up on the left side of the screen, no matter where I am on the screen, I can press left and it'll take me towards that side of the screen.
Um, and I liked it for a minute, but I, I pretty quickly went back to the first control scheme scheme because I think the problem for me with control scheme A is that it's harder to be fluid, like to have fluid motion.
Because if you're, if you press up, once you reach the uppermost point of the screen, you do an abrupt stop in any direction that you're going.
So that kind of, uh, while, while the other, the other control scheme might have a little more of a learning curve, I think if you have much more of a handle over it with that.
Yeah. It's essentially the same like argument for like, if you're playing like an old school, uh, survival horror, not, not quite as old school as Friday the 13th, but like resident evil, um, where whether you're doing tank controls, which again, it's just clockwise or counterclockwise.
Or if you're doing like absolute directionality of whatever, uh, uh, whatever camera angle you have, I think it's sort of, you run into the same problems with both where you can get turned around basically, uh, with the, uh, with tank controls, but it is, it's basically more, uh, consistent, at least in my opinion.
I don't know if you guys see the same similarities there.
You know, I think that's all, that all makes sense to me.
I was a control B guy as well.
Uh, but I also think like this might not have been just the best decision for a control scheme with a D pad, you know, like, like for a D pad, it's suffices.
I don't know what they even did at the arcade to be honest, but it feels like the actual correct way to play this game would be with a, like a wheel, right?
And just like spinning around in a wheel to understand the direction at all times.
And like, that's something they could have done at the arcade, I suppose, but I don't think they did.
That's kind of what I'm looking for.
But I wonder, can you guys think of a better way to handle controlling yourself around the ship?
It would take an analog shit, an analog stick, I think.
Uh, if it's just going to be D pad, I think it has to be one of these two situations.
Yeah, I, I don't know.
I was also a control B guy.
I tried to do control A for the, for a while, because I thought it was interesting that they have this kind of unique scheme, but sort of what everyone's been saying, it's a little bit too context dependent.
Like if you're on this side of the screen, then up will send you up in this direction.
But if you're on this side of the screen, up will send you up in the other direction.
And it just got a little bit too confusing for muscle memory's sake for me.
So I went back to A and B, but I wasn't, uh, Arkanoid or something.
The one that had a dial.
It did have a dial.
Yes, it had a dial controller.
Yeah, I think that would be perfect for this game.
I wonder if it would work.
It's an NES controller.
I feel I would love to try that.
Oh, so Arkanoid came with the controller?
It came, it came on the NES with a dial controller that you could plug in.
And that's how you could play specific to Arkanoid.
But I don't see why it wouldn't work if you plugged in.
I mean, it only has one other button.
So you wouldn't be able to use your special power up, but you would be able to fire the blaster theoretically.
Interesting. But maybe you wouldn't even be able to start the game.
I don't know. I don't have that controller.
Yeah, but I think if they had made it, if they had made it like that, but with a, another button, I guess.
Yeah, totally.
Another interesting thing about being in a circle, and I think Joe touched on this when he was explaining the game, is that the enemies, they fly in mostly from the outside.
Some come directly from the center.
But when they fly from the outside, as far as I could tell, they actually don't hurt you on their way in.
Like, you can't accidentally be surprised by like a jump scare alien ship that then like hit you immediately.
Like they get to fly into the center.
And then as they get closer, as they work their way from the center back to you, that's when they're on the attack.
But where they place themselves in the center matters because you're shooting into deep space.
So you can't just be on like the left side and hit something on the right.
You'll just shoot into the left side of deep space.
You have to go over there and it's a little more precise than what we're used to usually with shmups that are either horizontal or vertical because those you just shoot across the screen.
And if it ever makes contact, it makes contact.
This you're kind of shooting into a void.
So I like the enemies can't hit you right off the bat and just, you know, take free lives from you.
But there's also like this interesting challenge of not letting the enemies develop quick enough so that there's too many on a side or that things become overwhelming.
Like you kind of have to attack them while they're far out because the closer they get back to the outer circle, the tougher it's going to be for the player.
Yeah, I think that if they were to make you like allowed to get hit as they're coming in, this that would have been a deal breaker to play this game at all.
But no, I do.
I do like the idea of again, it's sort of like a crowd control thing.
But I guess a lot of shmups are like that where you're just trying to make sure that they can't get back to you because there are a lot of enemy types that at least later in the game make it pretty easy for them to get right up in your grill.
And that's sort of what you're trying to avoid the whole time.
There's also this weird design decision, though, that like, and I don't know if it's because the game is an architecture.
Arcade game, so it's mostly based around points.
But if you're not on the same, you know, plane as those enemies, let's say you're at the bottom of the circle and they're approaching from the top,
they're just going to kind of continue to drift out into the corners of the screen until they are no more.
And there's no penalty for missing them.
You just don't get those points.
But theoretically, you could do like a pacifist run where you don't really shoot at anything and just wait till everything enters the center of the screen and then clears back out.
And then you'd be able to move on to the next stage, which are referred to as warps in this game.
I think that that's a little weird.
Can you confirm that?
Have you tried?
Have you to play a pacifist run?
Or at least like for one level.
Yes, I didn't do a complete like I did.
I did shoot things, but I definitely was able to let a significant amount of things go by and then and move on to the next level.
They don't just continue to spawn.
Gotcha. It's like I wouldn't.
I wouldn't have known because I was I was shooting stuff.
But I was wondering if it was like it keeps going until you clear or you kill this many enemies.
But I guess no, it's just on a timer.
So that's best I could tell. It's either a timer or a set pattern.
You know, like once it's spawned the last one for that level and granted the levels do get a little bit longer.
Once it's spawned that last one, that's like that's it.
And you either get the points or you don't.
What about the structures that come up in levels that are like mini bosses almost that those you have to take care of?
Yeah, right. You have they don't leave the center.
OK, I wondered about what you were saying to about like since other than those big structures that Sam just mentioned, can you know, could you just go through the whole game?
And like what's the penalty for not doing it?
And my thought on it is just that you probably could do it and you're probably going to it's probably going to be a harder game for doing that.
So it doesn't feel like you're cheating by doing that.
Like the reason my incentive for shooting as much as I could was to get things out of my way, you know, and I let things go by when they weren't bothering me.
But usually I wanted to kind of clear things off the screen so it was never congested, you know.
And plus, I think the more the more you kill, you get more ultra lasonic phaser boosters, which makes the bosses easier.
Right. And also, like, do you want to let Genghis Khan have that last laugh of like you didn't you didn't fight his fleet off?
And anybody you let go by is just going to go back to Pluto and clear out that house because you're not there anymore.
Right. Yeah. Do you think that like if you let them go by, but then you wind up getting to Genghis Khan that like that's it?
Like they're just going to give up?
They're going to be like, ah, you know what?
We're done taking over Pluto.
Actually, this is this this war was for naught.
Yeah, I think there's an alternate ending.
Yeah, they just keep going out into deep space like they don't stop since we're talking about the game here.
I feel like we missed the biggest thing, the eye opening moment for me, at least starting this game and hearing Takata and Fugue and D minor.
Wow. That was impressive for NES sounds, but also just like really brought on the like, OK, like, let's do this.
Like I am ready to take down this this dreadful fleet of enemies.
And then the rest of the music is pretty is pretty playful and exciting.
And, you know, it's a fast boost of stuff.
But I don't know. There was like an adrenaline kick to that like eight bit version of Takata and Fugue.
Yeah, no, I like the music.
I didn't recognize it.
I don't know how I didn't recognize it.
But it is very energetic.
And Sam, you're telling me you felt nothing?
When that song came on?
When that song came on, you weren't like, whoa, that's that's awesome.
I thought it sounds awesome.
I thought it was cool.
But like my first reaction whenever I hear a song that is not there, like whatever, whatever the game is not.
My first reaction when I hear a song that's not original and specific to the game is like, oh, they just picked a different song.
They didn't come up with one on their own, you know, and even though shame Konami.
I mean, a little bit.
That's just how I react to it.
Because I feel like you have the chance to set the stage for this game.
It's your game.
You did the art. You did the, you know, the gameplay, the coding, all of it.
Like, why would you use someone else's song in it?
It just that seems a little weird to me.
I don't know. I mean, I kind of thought a little bit of that, especially honestly, particularly because it was such a recognizable song.
And it's just so like, it almost feels like a parody at this point because that's like in everything that's supposed to be like ominous.
It was like that. It was maybe that choice that actually threw me off a little bit.
But I'll say that I completely have, it doesn't bother me at all because of how good I think the rest of the music is in this game.
I think it's pretty good. Yeah, there's something about the music in the game.
Because it's so fast and fun, it complements the stages well, too, because we haven't talked about this.
But the stages are pretty short bursts of enemies.
And you can clear through warps pretty fast.
I'd say it's like maybe a minute, minute and a half of total gameplay for a warp stage before you move on to the next one.
And that was like really refreshing that it wasn't like a five minute long stage and there's 39 of these and it's going to take forever.
And granted, you know, do the math, it is still a very long game.
But I liked how quick and energetic it was at the start to allow you to flow.
I think you can get from Neptune to Pluto relatively quickly.
Yeah, I appreciated that.
And like the between planets, which basically are just the boss battles, they do sort of change up the...
I mean, the basic gameplay doesn't change from level to level, but at least they will throw different patterns at you.
So it's not like a minute of one thing and then another minute of the exact same thing.
They do some things to spice it up.
Between these like mini levels or warps, I guess.
But I guess they could have also just squished them all together and it would have just been like nine or ten, like five minute long levels.
But I guess there's no reason to do one or the other.
But I did like the bite-sized nature of them.
I also think it was cool the way that they made a few levels between each planet, but still the planets being like recognizable landmarks were like a nice little bookmark for you, the player, to make you feel like you're making progress.
For sure. Yeah, that's what I was gonna say.
I think it's more about the progress in the decision to make it bite-sized.
I don't think that's like something that would work for every game.
I think like Bionic Commando would be really weird if they were just like short one and a half minute levels and then you just kept moving across.
You're like, I'm doing something.
You know, in games like that, it kind of does help to pad out the levels to make them feel more epic.
This, I don't know, something about like the way you clear out ships, the music, the speed at which you're moving at too around the circle to take care of the different enemies.
It just felt like it worked really well for being bite-sized.
And also with the arcade nature of the game, just made everything feel like it was moving a lot quicker than it probably was.
Because 39 stages is an awful large amount of stages.
Yeah, and it's just nice to like, while they have like the different stages between the planets, it's just nice to not necessarily just be like,
all right, I'm on stage one and I'm about to be on stage two.
It's like, I'm at Neptune.
Like, I can contextualize that and it makes it feel a little cooler.
Yeah, it feels more like a journey.
Yeah. I also think it's like if you die and I don't know, in other games, going back to the beginning of a level is like,
a really weighty penalty.
And I didn't really die that much in this game.
So I'm trying to think if that's the penalty for a restart or a game over.
But just something...
You're asking when you get hit?
Not when you get hit, but when you run out of lives.
Then the whole game... Oh, I think when you run out of lives, I think that's game over.
That's game over. Okay, then I just...
Never mind that. But I also enjoyed the bite-sized nature of it.
And it does feel like you're progressing really well.
I also appreciated that in the beginning, you can kind of see a pattern of what the bosses are like,
where I think the first two are just, you know, blow up these little eyes.
And then you move on to another boss and it's just got more eyes that you have to blow up.
And they more or less stuck to that.
But there were a few planets that had something new.
Like, I think Earth, you fight three other spaceships that are kind of like you,
but coming from the inside.
And I forgot what planet has a boss that's like an orb with arms.
Oh, yeah. That was...
I think that's either the end of Pluto or the end of Urinet.
Yeah. So I appreciate that they didn't just stick to the same skeleton for each boss,
even though a lot of them are kind of the same, just with more bulbs.
Well, would you be shocked if I told you that boss battles were added specifically for the NES version of this game?
They didn't exist in the arcade.
That I didn't know.
The arcade version didn't have boss battles and also didn't have the super blaster.
I don't know what you called it, Sean.
You had a very fancy name for it.
But that B button that does like a super powered attack that can kind of just kill enemies in one shot,
that didn't exist in the arcade either.
And I feel like that's very surprising that the NES got things that the arcade version didn't.
So you're telling me that the arcade version only had the Neo-Teutonic cannon or the Neo-Bomblastic cannons?
There was no ultra-lazonic phaser booster?
There were no ultra-lazonic phaser boosters in...
Can you imagine? Yes.
I know, Joe, the nerve of the arcade version to just be like, you know what?
This is actually just a game.
Well, you know what? Because here's the thing.
We haven't talked about it, but this arcade game is old.
Like, the NES is getting this game in 89, but I think it came out in like 83, the arcade,
and was clearly doing like Tempest meets Galaga.
So, you know, they probably just didn't think that they needed much more than that,
considering what was successful at the time.
But I think it's just wild to think that the, you know, we're always ragging on NES games
for being like, well, you know, the arcade version, the graphics look better,
and it has more going for it, and it's more fun.
I don't know. Here, I'm actually shocked.
Like, the NES version is like the feature-complete version of this game.
It's another...
The word of the day is refreshing that we're not playing the dregs.
And we talked about saving the solar system,
as opposed to just some other made-up planets that the developers would make.
And, Sam, I think you said that felt like a journey.
I like that description, because I do think that saving our solar system
is something important in terms of investment at this early on in video games
that we haven't really seen, right?
Like, sometimes you get World War II games or whatever,
and those are like, you know, relive history in video games.
But this is like sci-fi meets grounded...
Not reality, but groundedness in some kind of way, you know?
Yeah, I don't...
I mean, I guess so.
If you don't read the manual,
and especially if you don't have the extra appendix that you have,
it just looks like you're shooting at aliens
until at the very end you have to fight the sun.
The sun has like a tummy ache or something,
and then you have to make it not hurt anymore,
and then at the end it just says,
there is peace in the universe.
So I don't really know how grounded fighting the sun is,
but I see what you're saying.
At least it's real places.
I like the idea that the peace in the universe
was just like a coincidence.
Like, you get to this... You defeat the thing at the sun,
and it's like, oh, check it out!
There's peace in the universe! I also just like the fact that the ultimate goal of this
is to save the sun.
Well, that's what was holding us back from peace, right?
It's like, we don't know it,
but we actually have an evil sun now.
You know how like in Majora's Mask,
the moon is evil?
Like, the sun in our reality is actually evil,
and we just have to beat it
in order to achieve world peace.
Yeah, maybe it's like the Mario sun.
Oh, the angry sun.
Yeah, terrifying.
But yeah, even in the manual though,
it says, ultimate victory will occur only after you free
the solar system's life-regenerating sun.
So it's basically saying that
they're holding the sun hostage.
And I feel like it's got some...
What's that? Stockholm Syndrome.
It's like the sun fights you.
I don't appreciate that.
So there is a lack of power-ups in this game.
That's usually what we talk about
when we talk about shmups.
I don't even know if the dual blaster thing
even counts as a power-up.
You get it almost immediately,
and then it's like,
does it... Is it even more powerful?
Like what? Now it takes like half as many shots?
I doubt it. It felt like it was not doing anything at all.
So what do you think?
Like, should there have been power-ups
that make it so this way
you can shoot from, you know, different...
Like, I don't even know what you would do
because you're going on a cylinder here,
but like, could you shoot in a spread
or shoot from behind you
or a laser that could go across the center
and actually hit those things over on the other side?
Would that just have made the game too easy?
Did you not care the power-ups weren't on there?
Somebody saved me from talking too much?
I was just gonna say, I think that it could have been cool
to have more power-ups. I do think that they'd have to increase the difficulty,
but it'd be nice to see...
I don't even know what it is,
but once in a while you hit something
and like two little stars come out
and they spiral around the outside.
You just said exactly two points
I was about to exactly say.
We should have just said them together.
We should have just said them in unison. Yeah, I think that this game is really
on the easier end of the shmups that we've played.
So it would definitely need a difficulty spike
to need power-up.
And yeah, I also thought that
that was gonna do something.
I thought that that was gonna be like,
that's just a special way
to get stuff on the opposite side of the screen,
but I think it was just for flair.
Yeah. So it seems like a missed opportunity.
Oh, you're talking about... Wait, wait, wait, wait. You're talking about the thing
that goes around in the center,
those two dots, and then it connects with you?
Yeah. Yeah, I think it's when you get a level up
or when you get a light. Those give you the super blaster.
Yeah, those give you
the dual neobomblastic cannons.
Yes. But where do they come from?
The visual element of it
makes it look like it's supposed to hurt things.
Oh, yeah, yeah, sure, sure.
And it also just shows us
that they can do that.
So why not make a bullet that does that?
Yeah, exactly.
But to answer your question,
those come from the mines.
So you'll see these little sets of...
They look like jacks almost.
And there will sometimes be
a little object in the middle of them,
and if you hit the object
in the middle of them,
that's what releases
those two little things.
And that will give you
the dual blasters.
Oh, okay.
Yeah. Cool. See, I like that.
I like that context. I wish I had noticed that
because it kind of makes it a little...
It's nice that it wasn't just
pick up this power up.
That kind of goes into...
Or for me, that kind of goes into this
issue that I have with the game
a little bit, which is that because of the nature...
Because they want to show
that you're traveling forward
through space, they have the background
kind of coming at you
a little bit. But that's also how
all the projectiles
travel at that same speed.
And sometimes, for me,
I found that I got
the projectiles a little bit
confused with the objects
in the background. So it just seems...
Yeah, I can see that. It seems a little busy.
And so when those things
come around, it...
I don't know.
I think it'd be interesting
to see more objects
behave that way,
whether it's things
that fire at you
or you have to
outrun things on the outside
that are...
I think I said
the opposite of what
I meant to say. You firing those
at enemies
or having to outrun
projectiles that the enemies
fire at you that behave that way
to a certain point.
Yeah, it would have definitely changed that.
And to your point about them looking confusing
because they look like
the stars that are
coming at you, I think one thing
they could have done to make it a little easier
is make all the stars
one color. The stars are like
a multi... It looks like a Pop-Tart.
It's just like a multicolored
thing of sprinkles
coming at you. So then when a projectile
comes at you, it kind of blends in
because no matter what color it is,
there are a couple stars
around that are that same color
moving in the same direction
at the same speed. Well, you should be
dodging the stars too.
Just get good. Oh, right.
Right, I should. So, 39 stages.
Chance stages, which are kind of like
no consequence,
shoot all the enemies
and get points.
Boss battles
and traveling across
the nine different planets
plus a boss fight
with the sun, as John mentioned.
Is there enough here
for you guys to continue to play
through the entire game
regardless of, you know,
whether you're good enough to get there?
Did this game
with everything that it has
in it right now
hold your attention
or were you hoping
for more as the game went on?
It's pretty low content
compared to what we've been playing recently.
I think this would fit
better in the early days,
like 86. This would sort of
be more
among its peers
in terms of like how much content
is in the game. We did get more
than what was
in the arcade version,
but I still think
that it's not quite
a full priced game
if we're going by that.
Yeah, I completely agree
like that.
I do think I would have
seen it differently
early on,
but also, I mean,
I've got to say I'm just not the guy
to tell you.
You know, like me personally,
no, it didn't hold my attention,
but that doesn't mean I think it was bad
or wouldn't hold anyone's attention.
Probably someone who likes shmups
would really enjoy it,
but that's why
I find these games
so much harder to judge
just because of my personal
opinion on shmups,
you know, is not particularly
positive, which doesn't mean
that I think that the game
is bad for everyone.
It's just not my cup of tea.
I think that the
gameplay loop
is good, though,
and even though
there's not a lot
of variation, the main thing
that you do in this game
feels good
to do
over and over,
and the fact that it's in these
little bite-sized bits
helps a lot,
and I think that helps
make you want to
go more because you know,
oh, it's just this much
until I get there, and this much until I get
to the bonus stage, or chance stage,
and a chance to
increase my weapons
if, let's say,
I just died or something.
And, I don't know,
I feel like there
isn't a lot in it,
but it still, it still makes you
want to play
just a little bit more,
and then that kind of
becomes a little bit addictive.
And also, Yeah, it's not Pac-Man,
mow your lawn levels of satisfying,
but there is
something satisfying about clearing things
out from the center
and the short-bursted
nature of the game.
Yeah, I, I think it did
give me that satisfaction
for a little while and make me want
to keep going. But I think that
the loop being repetitive,
which is fine, but combined with
the difficulty never
really seeming to get
that much harder,
didn't, kind of made it to
about halfway through
the game. I was like, well, that was fun,
and it was fun being
repetitive for about half the game.
Maybe it would have gotten better in the
second half, but for me personally,
I was like, okay, like,
I don't think I need
to keep going. It's funny because I
would say, past Saturn,
all of a sudden,
the game does that
thing that most people
hate, where all of a sudden
it just gets
a lot more difficult.
And I don't know if I,
I wouldn't say it became
like an incredibly hard game.
It was no Ghosts and Goblins
or anything. It just, for some reason,
after Saturn felt like
to me, all of a sudden, I was actually dying.
I actually had to be like,
oh, I'm probably going to run out of lives.
Like, there's just something
about that moment that I remembered.
And I didn't, I never beat the game
in its entirety just because of the
difficulty picking up,
not because of me
not wanting to beat it.
Yeah, I think that was more
of like a difficulty
plateau. Like,
there's only really two or three
difficulty levels
in this game. Like,
after Saturn is definitely
one of them. And I think
once you hit Earth,
things get a little
more dicey.
But it's, it's much more,
it's a much
gentler gradient
than I'm used to.
And I, I guess usually
I'm complaining about
these games being too hard,
but I think that
this hasn't quite hit
that middle level
of challenge.
Because I was able
to beat the game. I was losing lives,
but I was able to beat it,
which is weird for a shmup for me.
Well, that's awesome.
And that's why you know so much
about this sun battle.
Oh, the sun's in that game?
Oh, the sun says that.
All right.
Uh, development time.
I have a small
little anecdote here
about Dyrus. It is the second
and last game
that Yoshiki Akamoto
designed for Konami.
Now, that might be like,
okay, who's that? Why does that matter?
Apparently, Akamoto got into
paid disputes
with Konami
over the game and then was fired
after the release
of this game. So as retaliation,
he joined rival company
Capcom,
where he went on
to make 1942
and then produced
Street Fighter 2.
So I think
Konami
took a loss there
over what they
potentially should have
paid him for this game
only for him to go on
and make two amazing
franchises for Capcom.
Wow. So he was like
Kojima before Kojima.
Well, he wasn't the designer
of Street Fighter 2,
but, you know, anybody who's involved
in the making
of Street Fighter 2
is kind of a big deal,
right? Like, you're creating
an entire genre
and community that's worth
who knows how many
millions of dollars
today. For sure.
And then for sequels and spinoffs,
you know, it's interesting.
Many, many ports
of this game, but no true successor.
There's no Jirus,
Gyrus, anything.
You know, I figured they could
change it. Yeah, they could finally
change it to be
the other ways of spelling it.
There's none of that. And then there's also
just no, like,
spiritual successor
either. So instead,
I just want to talk about a couple
interesting things on the port side.
For the PlayStation
One, Jirus was actually
hidden inside of
Contra Legacy of War.
There was like a specific way you could
unlock Jirus,
and I'm like, wow, that's a weird game
to include in
Contra Legacy of War,
but whatever. So you can play it
on that, and apparently it's a
pretty good port
on the PlayStation One.
in the Game Boy Advance
version, if you put in
the Konami code,
instead of having it
with, like, the GBA graphics,
you get a
retro-ified version
of the game that also includes
three new warp levels
at the start of the game
before you then go on
to play the rest of the game.
That feels strange,
but I think they knew that nobody was going
to play through the entire game
and then get the three bonus stages.
Yeah. They just put them
up front. That's a good job there.
Yeah, but I mean, if people,
if that got out, people would have
incentive to play the game a second time.
Replay value. Yeah,
I mean, people do that
all the time for the Mario games,
right? Like, you'll buy
Super Mario Bros.
1 for who knows,
like, the fifth or sixth time
and then it'll turn out,
like, yeah,
if you beat the game
on eight times in a row,
like, it'll unlock Super Mario Bros.
2 Japan and people are like,
what? No way. Like,
and then they go do it.
Xbox 360 Arcade,
not, it didn't come out
for like Xbox 360,
it just came out on that arcade platform
if you guys remember that deal.
It was download only,
you need an online connection.
That is the same exact game
but with updated graphics
that, in my opinion,
have now aged pretty poorly
even just two console generations later.
So, I don't know if I would recommend that one
but it also came there.
So, it went to everything pretty much.
I didn't list off the other 14 consoles
but, neat to see that this game
continues to get some life
from Konami. Yeah,
uh, I can't really see how
a space game
that is this sort of bare bones
can look that bad
on the Xbox
but, I'll look up some,
uh, I'll look up some screenshots.
Oh, it's not even that it looks bad though,
right? Because it's like, they updated the graphics
so it's just like,
why? You know,
like, at that point, just release
the original,
like, arcade version
to Xbox 360 arcade.
Like, that's what it's called.
Anyway, we're gonna see
if this game
has some life of its own
since it never got any
sequels or spinoffs
when we decide
whether it's on
the Essential Games list.
All right, it's time for the
Essential Games list.
We're, uh, we're still in that
Essential drought
where there hasn't been
a single Essential game
in 1989
and I think every episode
somebody's like,
you know, that game should have been
Essential. Bandai Golf Challenge
Pebble Beach should have been Essential.
But, you know,
I think that we've been
doing an okay job so far
policing the neighborhood
and making sure
that the right games get on.
So let's take a look
at Jairus
and try to figure out
whether or not it's going to be
on the Essential Games list. Sam?
Oh, talking to me.
Okay. Um,
so going into this,
I was
pretty sure
that I wanted to make
this game Essential because
I thought it was,
it did something different
that I haven't really seen
a lot of games do
and I can't really think of
a game that's like this
and it had a fun
feedback loop and it was polished
and had great music
and all this stuff
but I think
that there's just
a little bit
lack of,
a little bit of a lack
of substance that would be required
for me to
feel comfortable
actually voting
it Essential. I think we need
something like a little bit
more variance for it
but it was really close for me
but I think
if you like shooters
like shmups
and especially
retro ones then definitely
give this one a try. Alright,
Joe? So I kind of
touched on it prematurely
earlier in the episode
but I have a hard time
with shmups. Well,
not just with playing shmups
but with voting for shmups.
I did enjoy
this game but I wonder
did I not enjoy it enough
just because
I'm not a shmup guy
or did I not enjoy it enough
because it's lacking?
And I do think
that in the end as much as I think
this is a great game
I don't think
that necessarily means that
it's a must
for today. And I do think
especially now after I played it
I kind of was looking around
on what people
think about this game and I do think
that this probably will be one
if it doesn't
get on which it looks like if I'm
voting a no then I guess
it can't but we probably
will get some messages.
So I'm not
saying I'm not open to reconsidering
in the best of 89 in like 30
years when we get there
but right now
I'm kind of with Sam
I liked it a lot
I think it was great but I
just don't think I don't think
there's anything about it that's
going to make me think like
I want to come back to this
over some of the other options
we've had or even just
at all so yeah
it's tough sorry if that's
a little vague or non-committal
but it's hard
for me to do it with shmups.
That's fine
that's fine Sean
give us your
vote. Yeah I'm kind
of with Sam where I'd say
that this is
lacking some
substance I think that
if it were
if there was
a little bit more variety
in power up
and a little
bit more
difficult to
accommodate for the
increase in
power that you have
maybe this
would be
one of my favorite shmup
but right now
it's it's
kind of it's lacking
in that regard
so I'm also
going to say this is not
a sentence. All right
three no's so
far but seems kind of
close. I will say
my mind was
pretty much
made up before we
recorded the episode
we talked some things
through and I think
that where I landed
is exactly
where I was
after I finished playing
this game yesterday
something about this game
it reminds me
of you hear
about games like Pac-Man
Galaga Donkey Kong
you know
those are really famous
arcade games
that you know
you can't get enough praise
about them but they're
kind of like spoiled for you
in a way because you either experience
them at a very young age
or you just
know enough about them
so when by time you get
to them there's not
like you didn't get that special
hook you know
like everybody has seen how
Donkey Kong is
done everybody's seen how
Pac-Man is played
so even if
you're playing it for the first time
it doesn't feel as special
something about
Jairus here
felt really
special to me as I was
playing it especially as
an arcade game
and knowing that the NES
version after
playing the arcade version too
knowing that the NES
version is
like just an
overall better
version of an arcade game
something that we didn't ever
think was possible
when we started
talking about you know
oh well this would go on our
essential arcade games list
but it can't go on the
essential NES games list
this really
feels like to me
it deserves to be on the essential
games list because it's
it's not even
a schmuck to me it's just
it's just an arcade game
it's just arcade fun
it's just it's silly
it's short
it's sweet it's enough
to keep me
hooked on that I wish
I could have beat the game
like I wanted to be good
enough to beat the game and I wanted
to keep going back to it
but it's also something that I
could see myself
just being like well if I can
only make it to Saturn who cares
anyway I'll do that
I'll just play through
that I wasn't trying to
keep track
of my score
at any time
and I wasn't also trying to
keep track of my progress
I just like
the short
bursted nature
of the game in many ways
for me the closest
thing I can think of
for NES
games is that
this is like balloon fight
you know people continue
to ask me why is balloon
fight on the essential games list
why does Mike love this game
so much it's just
enough simplicity
meets raw
fun you know
like balloon fight is
always going to be fun
to me and I think Jairus will
show that to me as time
goes on that this will
be a game I continue
to go back to
and I'm
just amazed that I never
experienced anything like
it before and I know
that's crazy right like we
played you know
20 years of video
games since then
I'm not
saying that this created a
new genre or anything
I really think that
this game just opened
my eyes to an experience
for an arcade game
that I didn't think I could have
after experience
so many arcade
games so for that
reason Jairus has
to go on the essential games list
for me I think
this NES version
is better than the arcade
version and so I
really don't have any complaints
putting it on there wow
well I'm sorry we
disappointed you but you know
what it was close it was close
we'll see we'll see what
happens in best of 89
but I think in the meantime
I think
everybody gave
solid answers for why
or why not they couldn't
put it on the list and that's
what this is all about at the end
of the day and it stays
a play it it stays
a play it right and you know
what I thought about recently
a little non sequitur here
though we have our
essential games list which are
the games that you should play
and then if it doesn't make
the essential games list
it becomes a play it
which are the games that you
should play so like you
know it's fun
to have the essential games but you can still
there's nowhere you can find
those list of games
on purpose essentially I like
the golden golden play it
then there's the golden play it
and then there's the play it
yeah where does
gyromite fall
on that list it's a bronze
just bronze
absolutely well you know
I think we can all
kind of agree that this is
you know one of the
nicer surprises
of 1989 so far
a lot of times
you know I don't think
any of us knew this game going
into it am I right I had no idea
what this was before I played
it I did not
I didn't either
no I never heard of it
I also did not
that's just
going to keep happening you know
we'll see what surprises
us next but
you know we've got
good games coming up
like another arcade classic
Q-Bert is our
next game of the week
so guys
Q-Bert any love
for the little orange man
I appreciate
Q-Bert I've never
actually played it so it'll
be interesting
same here and I'm just
looking down the list for like
what's the next game
that would just surprise
us and I think
it would have to go to
Mystery Quest
because that's
just vague enough that
nobody could have any idea
what that is about yeah I don't
know what is Mystery Quest
I'm guessing it's gonna
be a it's gonna
have some first person
parts in it but that's
just a guess I think it's
gonna be like gumshoe a one of a
kind game as well
all right well I think
that's all the time we have for this episode
of Nostalgia
thanks for joining us
and next week
as I mentioned we'll have Q-Bert
and then Tecmo
and then finally
a real RPG
Ultima 3
Exodus so keep
keep it here because we've
definitely got a lot more coming
we have that
game jam which you can
hear more about in our post show
right after Sam's awesome
ending song
which is kind of
like the intro song but
just the second
half of that which is
it feels more like an ending
that way yeah it feels
more fanatic
is that no that's not
a word I'm a fanatic
yeah it has
some finality to it
there you go I'm a fanatic
for Sam's music
I'm the Philly fanatic
he pisses off
a lot of people and so do you
so that makes sense
absolutely you can always
find Nostalgia
at Nostalgia
Cast on Twitter you can find me
Michael Esposito
at Esposito Film
on Twitter and we'll be
talking to you real soon
and it's a very
exciting day
here for Nostalgia
whether you listen at 8 in
the morning or 11pm
as long as you're listening on
Friday March 19th
the date we release this episode
this is also the
day that we
started our
Nostalgia Game
Jam with listeners
from all over
joined in
and some of them
are going to make some really cool
games but I don't know
anything about making games
so I'm actually going to throw
this over to Sam who could
explain what our Game Jam
you know how that process
goes on and what these
next two weeks are going to be
like so Sam why don't you
take it away alright
well it's not
quite two weeks
that this lasts
that's why I
already threw it to you I just knew
I couldn't handle the
stress of explaining it
so the Game Jam
goes from March
19th which is
today if you're
listening to this on Friday the
19th until
March 28th
which I believe is the following
Sunday
next Sunday
at 11pm
and during that
time period the goal is
to create
to conceptualize
and then program
and then publish
a game that
looks like it
could have been an NES game
so it should
all the games
will be in
256 by 240
resolution they should all
sound like an
NES and the control
scheme should
reflect the NES
controller in some
capacity whether that's
you know however you want
to map the controls
there should be a d-pad
start select
and an A
and B button somehow
incorporated
into it and that's
about it we're also going to have
an optional theme that
I guess at this point
will be announced and if you
are making
games I guess
this is if you're
listening to this and you say
like wow I'm not doing anything
this weekend that sounds great
then you can go over to
itch.io
and look at the game jam
section and it'll
be going on you can sign up
right away that sounds
jammerific there we go
I think we got
one but also
if you want to just
check out the game
jam and just
kind of stay tuned
on it these
people will be submitting
their games so you can
play them and see what
you think of them and that's what we're going
to do we're going to play the games once
the game jam is over
and then we're going to
talk about them on a
special episode of the podcast
and it's going to be super
fun and I think that's
about it I agree
with all of that and
now that we have Joe's
sign off there's nothing
else we can do except
wait until
the fabled
March 28th
assuming it happens this
year and if
it does that's when the jam
will end and we'll start
diving into these games
and we'll
give you an episode when
can't say for
certain soon
absolutely but
what really is soon in the
concept time you'll just
have to keep listening to
nostalgia every
Friday at
8 a.m. specifically we
want we're going to start deleting
the episodes at 9 a.m.
so make sure you save them
fast I kid of
course nothing
gets deleted everything is
forever and so is nostalgia so
keep checking in
and keep listening and enjoy your
week or whatever you do